four weeks
ago i was scared to be fair so
four weeks ago we yoghurt
stopped the podcast with
finnair exactly and since that was 50 percent of my
daily volume i.e. work as well as 50
percent of my income so there
i was already like
running running running  12 shortly before
christmas my podcast will come out
maybe of the year don't know too
well know city a lot going on this
year i know from experience a
very very well
listened episode will interest a lot of people about the life of paul ripke and me  yes
too and we thought about it i was
able to persuade myself again to the end of
a very very eventful year leads
i think i can maybe also
talk to him and come over you are
still in germany and you
also asked for you then i was
surprised though  don't say why
what we premiere all
advertising together here can speak live
in port that I was allowed to al  so
looking forward to the
turnaround I'll see if I can change something
hello hello thank you very much for letting me come
by here and I thought
why not let the guest do the
advertising too and I wanted to be
willing I
didn't realize that
telecommunications companies also  there are
others but we will then
hear that in the advertising we will then do it live, so to speak
, in the with roll and
ok it was just now or are
we going to do it
now it means was state parliament and i'm
not sure if you even know that
vahland i
am  not quite to me no it's something
e-commerce explain to me something
what makes a convergent
or why software providers
are becoming more equal tell me that women are
becoming equal in software providers do
n't just understand the the the solutions you can
get with software the situation
wishes in the area we give how
soundproof advertisements how will i be
dismayed by various processes
software in the end a lot of
software
products can offer the same things so ok it’s totally difficult to discover
for the respective software purchases on the company’s
side it
all sounds so similar it’s supposed to
be all the same here how do i take it
ok now and then there’s the
antique ones  play they know each other
in depth with individual products so well
to say okay we will help you to find the
right service service saas
software for your very specific
needs also in terms of price of course what
suits that children
implement well and then they make
the selection  implementation the
whole support okay if
i do clothes with perry and if
i make a shop software for
example they have something like that i say
then you are probably now although
you can't mention that already
with the relatively big  has become
but I assume they start with
medium-sized firms  en the really
larger software suite
you are yes but holds up very well so
I am head of software purchasing
directly online but so a kind of
comparison provider who have a
knowledge city race what happened there
is very person-driven and
look back in but  they say they
cover 70 percent of the available
commerce technologies
i.e. the ecommerce consultant and think about them and have
600 people who know their way around and then discovered
the right systems
for you from a commercial organizational technological point of view
ok and is there a
link where i can read it again  it
came loud absolutely while with v wall antique
point comes slash and won't run because an
tig came end or with ten not very much
and was quite okay a better
private we have further so now
always very short we already have harry
last year is  here what your own
fashion brand brazil
together a long time ago correct
then taken from pari f  for politicians the
candlesticks good very good sensational the
eternally behind us it was so this
year was very difficult for me in
terms of financing so
cash flow was a problem because I didn't
take out any loans that I had never
done before and had never financed
anything  in my life i think that's
pretty stupid
yes and i've already reached the limits of being able to
finance it because
a lack of raw materials is a problem we
produce in turkey so we had
quite a lot of cotton problems
we had procurement problems so the
collections came too late 22 months
three  months of summer
collections then i
increased them because it was clear i could no longer
order internally for the christmas business and
for the november business all of
a sudden i had a 920,000 euro bill
for a collection because i just
increased the quantities they spread they
are that i could do that  sometimes
not so left right lift somehow so short
d  a I was on the verge of
bankruptcy I have to say the
account balance was moderate and that was before
it was tight but everything worked out and
now of course
everything is correct I
borrowed money myself sold a bit of
bitcoin so to speak that was  then also okay
and
but still have no so zero credit
in it still have a lot
of goods when the inventory was in between no
idea two and a half million or something of course that's
so stupid it's
far too much goods what I
had put down but on the other hand  Of
course I'm benefiting from that now that I was able to
serve the league super will quickly
mean somehow yes exactly I don't think the
word black friday is so cool
insolvent we the animal weighs but
still it's a time when very
discounted are offered because we
order 12,000 or  done something like that in five days,
which is a lot for us and
now it's Christmas business, which also attracts
a lot  d i can handle all of
that i still have it so i
'm not sold out and i was
isn't somehow to say now
that it's not cool anymore because
the mesum trends is that i should have that
holds up in berlin yeah i
can't do that  really judge well because
there is also that you have to
say that well i must have designed 56 things
which i then think up
some nonsense that did
n't sell at all that's a really
stupid idea was that you
interestingly designed sweatshirts for example
so what is this so
sweatshirts in colors sell
very badly build what i don't
understand because the sweatshirts in one
color sell really well but have to be so brave
it's sometimes very loud very
central so california beach-
like sweatshirts don't work so well either
and  we just have a few
slow sellers also that it's all train
gentlemen so the right with stella
black the cat gan  z clear so it's still the
case that
75 percent of the sales are in
Germany or Germany Austria Switzerland
and those are black products point
so Germans aren't colored
I understand that too so I myself they wear
quite a lot of black when  I
don't stand out now if you don't want to
always like a blob of color
the cat and but also I've done the
following this year
I would have walked away from the cat quite a bit
because I've made up my mind to
at least try in that
direction perceived as a brand  to become that
means i used the word pari
then used paris sports club and
newport beach again as text so it
's less cat and much much more
paris next year will be
return of the cat again so there will be
more cat products again  for me it was
a bit i wanted to find a bit
more identity in my own
products with the name
ic  h very much i changed the cut again
for one the quality
so i am now finally the
summer collection was for the first time
so the route was exactly how
i wanted it that a bit oversize
240 grams so solid dollar cotton
and the  cut so that I got a bit of
hip hop I'm honest, so to speak, and
it took a year and a half, two years
, until you got there, like an
adaptation and there it was a bit bigger
and a bit different, and
now and then I just wanted to too  yes
i tried to use a bit more par
can say how big is
business medal won the well well
we doubled it in terms of sales
last year but still
seven digits so in
terms of sales maintenance so i have
compared when i talk to other people
and  i exchange
ideas a lot like that's awesome because a lot of people are
very very open to it, they all have
higher profit margins trainer a  ls me
so I have a very low contribution
margin
no idea I don't know
so maybe I'm stupid who was
produced for 25 and sold
and for 60
e.g. purely production and transported
and then
there's something on top of that and so  our factor is
two and a half, about a maximum of 2
and that's different for others
but i think it can only be one
product because of course you
now have expensive production costs
and marketing don't have how you
sell it essentially through a
personality choice correct yes yes at
all  don't notice also totally and i
produce everything we then see
every photo everyone thinks it would
n't be a photo trip what can you say that you have to be sure
rent mandl
location pay models and stuff but
now that the costs are relatively
low for other things  but
maybe it's also because other
people approach it more realistically and in h  o
tschi 410 euros I personally
want to throw
but that so
I only want to sell the 65 euros
maximum that is that I find the
reasonable price for this product
I claim that I could also
sell it from 90 but there comes my
dead pants school so only because  if you can do it
you shouldn't do it for a long time
you get a lot much further
i think if you do what you
find appropriate that's well it
got me very far as a photographer
to say quite often like hey what do
you have as  budget what
do we do this and that and not
that well i'm satisfied because i'm not
always glad
i would have gone more if i could have
gotten more money
or something like that but i
asked for it then i asked for  told me
for 500 euros we'll do a
photo job and then I never
questioned again whether that could also be for a thousand,
maybe 1000 could
have been in it like we did  d and that's why he is
the wish father of the thought and so
i work at perry all the
time i want to sell a poly for 65
if i decide that his
label comes
on the back and zips and suddenly the
product costs 28 euros instead  20 then
it's my decision that does
n't mean that I'll
sell it all at once for 75 even if I could do it
I still do a lot and I
'm already living I think it's much nicer to
surprise with a good product in the
end and that's what happens  people
write me lots and lots of crass i
didn't expect such quality and they
stay longer and the dead pants
always have before every shitty
concert the 100 years discuss whether the
ticket costs 53 70 or 54 10 euros so they
and i sat the one and a half  hours
in the so-called blue hour in
which there and the
one and a half hour discussion about 40 cent ticket
differentiated and then I say why
was what is  what is wrong with
you then they say well for
anyone who is at this concert
it is the last Toten Hosen
concert because he will die for
someone it is also the first
Toten Hosen concert because he has never been to
the Toten Hosen concert both have
actually  a better experience if
you pay 40 cents less without a
discussion somewhere anyway we still earn
we don't pay on top of that it's
not that we do anything whatever we're doing
it faithfully and
it's sensational we can make a great
living from it we can somehow
feed the family that everything is fine why is it
greedy why take 110 euros just because
we could because that's exactly when there
will be at some point and i think
so that it's also in music it
's much more intense than dependent
on what you feel  experience is so it is and that's the way it
is in photography
too there is no such thing as an
absolute  so and to be honest
the clothes are
not that you rate a product
by the quality of the cotton and the type of
cut processing or say something like that it
is some kind of lifestyle
pohl has it for me and she had to
come up with one in the end
super small topic there is yes that is
with us
so these fiat reinhardts he then brought in
including the 39 correct which is
bad because you are really a lot of
admin and logistics and patrons but well
we are just blueprint com well so I
have one  good ear singh about bernd von
geldern with here the old st pauli
connection so there where the skull
and crossbones pants are made is next to it
and we used to do
that at seyhan it just means
yes this seat in istanbul and produces
i have a big one  trust i've been
there many times that's a no
child labor no thinks is a clean
certified adidas certified
factories what i lost so much  The good thing is that
it's not just some subcontractor from
Bulgaria who then sends a portugal at some point
and all of a sudden
you think it's postage it's really
Europe's really Turkey and that's
completely out of the question
I do it myself and Bernd helps me a
lot when  there is a question then
there is actually everything marketing
i do something like
that in terms of production so which photo series is whatever
then there is one person who does
customer service and in star- i.e.
customer inquiries and customer service
at the end where we are there too  we do
n't do returns we have an
outsourced warehouse in the middle of
germany right next to the head office
they are all is inquiry i had
forgotten the ashraf from mietnix bm
where he was also day and night does
the ins dm answer you do it even
if it makes sense  so it's out
party we'll do everything yes franzi does that
there isn't a single one and so I'll take a
look too  ds in and then says why
is it not responsible but so does the
super awesome job and answers
everything and if it's with me then
I sometimes make screenshots and says franzi
will look into the order because what I
don't do it  and
so sometimes I do that but I
myself if you write to me where are
my orders then only if I
really either it's up to Franz and
I say to them or I really check
but I rarely do that
and then say they  does
this loud come tomorrow at the
hour almost everything business celebrate
again everything just shopping everything just
drl we are right next to the turnstile
that's why we have 82% next day
ribéry for all folders until 3 p.m. is an
unbelievable number so i think so
that  It's really amazing how quickly
our things are there, customers notice that too,
so people say it's so awesome
I ordered yesterday, it's here today
and it's super cool to
move  re not even coming to us so it
comes from turkey directly to the
fulfillment we have the ultra
cool is so there is a kind of connector
the
micro is the name of the software so to speak
company startup from munich and they
connect the old world of logistics with the
new world of shopping  so to speak, we do
n't always talk well known that there is
also a Japanese podcast here and
I think I
briefly mentioned the last time and we
are still ultra happy in the megageil
are so expensive yes so it's not the
cheapest option  but the most
reliable and came with so pieck sven
helbig or then 10,000 then 2000
then 100 and so on that's great
that they can react to it so they can
also send ten times the
amount the next day
will always be and so I do
no idea i'm making an advent calendar at the moment
where i
actually i tried to score a
bit of chamber music every day  to win
us because i had problems with the
visa and and i believe in that
too there are people who
say why so i have 400
police to be fair also from the
sweatshirt with the pattern where we stop
still have 400 and they  I got it
for two euros and let's think
I don't care even if I
add the 420 produced by 18 euros
actually that's still a
quality that can be given away
that I can say thank you that I
can give it to someone and  the
majority of people appreciate that
at least my reasons they write to
me super cool thank you very much that I was
able to make it possible for me for two euros
I now have a present I ca
n’t blame anyone else it’s a mistake
so I’ve made a mistake I’ll phrase it but I’ll
say it too  I want to give back and
that's also true and ashraf is the
way he is, he
doesn't pretend anything and he's
not in  the clubhouse day about the
seven live hacks for online marketing
but that's the way it is and that's why it's
so successful, but you shouldn't
forget that, so you have to be 23 and well,
i really try my best with
the products and it's
great fun for me  to get a positive message
if someone says i think
the product is good i'm happy about
it look here and send me a photo
my child is somewhere or i
saw or know someone there yesterday
someone writes at the airport
coming across from paris' poly
others  and whatever that is just
so that fills me up totally
so what isn't afraid
to say to our clear somehow that is
somehow 50 million sales was one
day so the brand but also
to build at the end so no idea so I
have  with his friend or our
friend tarek 23 times on the phone
which i found very impressive that
he then takes the time and s  yes
okay then let's take an hour
about it was going crazy
what he would do because I would have
said what would you do so
here's
what he says of course well well
build sl business so he says the
location is very very  a lot of value
for him in the logical way who says
to include a strategic partner who
says, for example, as
defined, i want to sell in five years
and then
optimize everything to sell in five years,
among other things, a much broader sales
channel, so that's a problem  that I
we are dependent on me if I don't
sell posters we more or less
don't sell a little something but well we
don't have any other way than the direct
way and we also have marvin technik
so we have also adapted to the
fact that we
can and I can  not either, so i
couldn't
put a collection down there at peek & cloppenburg
because then i'd pay for it per sale
uftem car pulled the thesis closed
so and of course you might have to
raise prices but
maybe also how to get them because the purchase prices are a
bit harder I
have never negotiated on purchase prices
so I have if you say it costs 24
euros then I think  I do that and
I'm sure I can also
bargain down to 21 euros if I
would do that I think it's a great
luxury that we don't do what all of our subscriptions do
so you can see that other things we in the USA are
already doing
promised these  whole kit and so that they
do it super well then get their money
in which they then do something for
adidas or for a little bmw the nba -
but I don't only have
positive products in these things, so there's just a
product of quality out of hand and there
were  a few things that i
didn't really think were super cool in the
end what he found as a result there is a
bit of a lottery game so no
idea and
a great
product is coming out with our good friend jochen dreissigacker, but there are also things
that i am not super happy with
collaborative 30 cent wine brand so a
winemaker
and since we are also partners there
make friends and there are a
few riesling paris longer  as a
person kester mayr concentrated is
my top program i have a
cook chamber
origin it says besides that
everyone else actually says richie
kitchen it's enough money that
it's not but
here not only his cell phone number the car would have in
on wednesday evening
wine just made out of the play
on words and so jochen makes the wine
i still have a bit of design and
packaging and marketing and i just like
the wine and but it i'm
not that big now so jochen
acknowledges yes that's a super power
is that the vintages and locations are
mixed so that a new one is that a
data mixed English that is the
mixed ebe  n grapes and way
and that one longer the other shorter
and that's how these special
highly successful wines are created and
that's why it's not in the vdp for
example in the association of German
predicate
wineries at the beginning that's what I heard because the
heydt contradicts things so it would have to be
vintage
taken ultra but still according to
old German rules you are not allowed to
mix vintages so you ca
n't mix three vintages and so
on and that but he is a real
pioneer he actually made things
new and i think that's so
crazy so that you are new to  thinking and
really blank sheet of paper and saying
but it's awesome aso as a product
and success proves the ultra right one of
these wines they have changed a bit
and this and that and that is
now with riesling and is
totally awesome makes you really want to do that  also
really relatively successful so
high-priced riesling is 30 euros in
the f  bottle and so first had to
sell in Germany and be 30 euros
because no idea I think 10,000
bottles only sold like that so when
the range men also over his
that's crazy so he has he brings
it works just as well for him as it does for
me  In the end, I
don't have a few of his customers either, because they find the story
interesting and what's
happening and I think it's that
quite a lot of restaurants
are going down now, so the family, there
are different Sony solutions and the
family is basically yes  always
actually need a story about the
crying and of course it's a
bit easier to say the guy from the
world cup finale who now lives in california
teamed up with mr
Thickeracker and that's how it
came about here so it's a simpler
story if you talk about products a
bit  wants to fill with life than
to say 247 times now it is very
calcareous and has a great
min  erality and so that
's also interchangeable what you
can tell about
wines it's super power in 22 seconds at a dinner like this
so now say independent of
parried by the braker you as a
person have a lot of brands apparently like
charged with stories
I have the feeling that you bring your story to brands
when you look like that I followed him on
instagram that's how it's
told there are already a surprising
number of brands who want to work with her
to do the story I also
believe that the future will
do that I no longer believe that you  as no
idea if you are now any
consumer brand can just do it on the install
channel
nobody cares so now no fans of the sparkling
water provider great water ruled one but when
the gerolsteiner instagram account
says hey we now have the sensitive
water with a different pink
sound on and label there, to be fair, you have to
say that out of 100 people are interested  en 0
there is no one out there
who cares if enemy hurry is written bigger
or smaller or something
so there is just
no real interest in consumption brands on social media i
think that's why they need
human stories and need rna
be through influenza through testimonials
through some human eising elements
so to continue humanly you have
interest again so something like that or iwc like
a bigger cola co with the hairstyles
and then you can if the whatsup
i can finally like that and
now we are at least
in talks again  like with similar fell
also somehow be allowed to be a partner do you want
to come by don't even want to go
to schaffhausen so i would
n't officially deposit myself as an iwc brand
ambassador i think i can
call myself that or whatever i
would like to invite to schaffhausen  it
's purely fall, right next door, the
brand new geba watch manufactory  well there
is actually so crazy so now
also further away from what I do
so that I'm not a
detail-loving miniature and loosely
followed step last 2 percent exactly that
's not my topic again
and to see that like the people here
really just spend hours with it
a millimeter again after
so unbelievable you have now made a
really awesome instagram film like
that drove through the area did you
say now watched advertising with the
sector yes whereby he was such a so
our common thing was a  film a
testimonial film that, by the way, with everyone
itself so i talk here all the time
i have to i know that it
is nice to be in love like that
and talk like that all the time at the
same time i still try to be
open because i have  that
helped that people were open the
other way around so please excuse me
what can you get for it as a
politician  so it's a so you
'll tell yourself the exact number but i
assume it's already six digits
yes
yes that was fundamental i have
various partnerships and they
are they are paid properly and
i only ever do annual cooperation
so i don't do it  and then we were up
i don't do something like that on the
weekends we do this and that but i do
something for me so what a longer
story that fills it with content
and that creates a lot of trust there so
american express is a great example
catch yes and here we are  we did
six things we first did something
for me at remote control where
people controlled me remotely i was
armed only with the platinum card
has left up right
hotel in the tent in you only need
the card and you can do it with it  into the
restaurant and water always and
transport judgments
just happened and actually this was
that one is ready for  no matter what comes
, it was simply filled with life
because no matter what the internet did to
me remote controlled i could
turn right left because i was armed with this
card and then we did
the event in germany travel
together and that was just one every
month  thing and that creates
at least a personal high level of
trust i.e. that shitty word
authenticity and everyone says it’s
authentic that lives from people
believing that they say okay and so
in that case i’ve been a
customer of this one for four years
product so I would now also
so with iwc I also took
pictures twelve years ago back then
and so I have a relationship
with the wanderers formula 1 4 years
with lewis hamilton quite a lot and
so I it is it has to  quite a
bit of history since his
business idea is one for the express and
correctly then you're doing
a little bit  also more
friendly when you meet waiter
i like to drink
what
i said i am a car partner i
would like so do you actually are
somehow there they recommend yeah yes i
wanted to do something with them and
i was also in bankruptcy with them
i was there  almost that was almost and it
hurts me a lot because that was two
years ago and that would have been a
bit ahead of time what we had
before and it was super awesome but it
was very event driven and
they were all cancelled
you can't do that either if a door
closes, so we both deliberately
said it doesn't make any sense, it
won't go back to the best
thing that the timing is so important in something like this,
the momentum that fits and then never
again like that  you can't
revive that so that was at the moment
you didn't because I'm worried
how you can hear it now then you make
these partnerships all financed
with it de  n building up the e-commerce
company,
which is also risky,
sometimes you worry about it’s
also just awesome earned money
probably a lot of people who are
now watching the neighborhood
think okay what kind of life of
duty he has  to the lofoten because
then it somehow becomes clear that you
can pay with a tool via spies
great because that’s how all
our stories like that happen it’s always
over that at some point the brands
say okay have the ribs now there was
that was really nice we know the target group
now  and at some point the topic is
just over and this life
can live yes that could very well be
but I'm not like that so I
was very interesting to
hear what tarek would do he's
smart enough to think about what will be
in five years  I don't have a chance
so now I know what I'm going to do next
year and that's
crazy enough for me as  o I have no
idea what I'll be doing in two years what
when 10 if we that's also cash
moderately normally you have let's say something like
a cushion but you know I
've always rented accommodation
I'd rather spend more money unnecessarily
so a lot of my  friends then
also agree but it doesn't make any
sense what you now get the bill
from what I've paid in rent for the last five years
I could have
bought the house myself which is now
worth twice as much yes that's true but I
knew  not at all if i
can afford it for five years i.e. this adaptation
and to be fair you have to i have
a wife three children and they are also
and you have to say that
too four weeks
ago i was scared to be fair
four weeks ago it was like that  that we joghurt
stopped the podcast with
finnair exactly and that was 50 percent of my
daily volume so it was work as well as 50
percent of my income so
I was already like that and partner  for next
year it wasn't so clear yet and whether it would
somehow continue or
whatever and then there was a moment for the first
time to be fair it was
then that my wife and and
somehow then yes we'll just move
somewhere else  well then we can
just do this live what
we can afford right now we can't
afford anymore then we'll move and to be
honest it's not that bad now
i should always go here in
hamburg for a moment we said if i
the brand  paul ripke should have steered
, let's say, since the world cup final the
breakthrough for you or dementia became too
famous then the books and
everything
i would have said okay full photographer
after somehow nico rosberg lewis
hamilton
either photograph the next story
try to get into usa basketball
with  the very best lakers make emi watch
dennis schröder i don't know
because so clean then sell really cool photos
i have ge  enough friends who
then hang the photos at home
because they are really cool and
pay 20 30,000 euros for your photos I
would have asked at the time
we could no longer sell a photo show
because I think that that somehow
really good design is cool but this one
things that you then have access as a
photographer and then I would still have
partnerships and then probably
how it is if you have a
photographer like that then no one calls
anyone laughs I’m ultra rich by the way
I would like to photograph my wedding
and what it costs jaaa marek
but 50,000 euros then you
somehow fly there if some german
dot com superstar marries you a few
photos
that would have been a life where i thought
there was really a lot of music
in it economically to sell these photos but it
will be my book is a book to make the
brand, so to speak  to build and
to go this way but you didn't do
why not
so I disagree  preche the economic
by the way so in the last ten years
i was in formula 1 who so
i earned very well there i had
a sensational contract as a
photographer and yes and niki lauda introduced
me a few times as saying
he was badly dressed  is and the
best-paid photographer in
formula 1 history that i always really
grabs and is therefore very proud and who
is
nevertheless i
earned a lot better economically in the years that followed
but the money photographers you are as a
photographer you have heard
correctly and yes
well well well now de facto was also co will so de
facto there was more or
less no longer my job in 2020 so
a photo trip to well I already
had a few jobs that took place there
, they were all canceled of course
because almost all travel things a
reportage things all photo trips all production trips have been
completely set to
zero so d  ann it
's so that i'm still not
absolutely convinced that my
quality my talent for photography is
really sufficient i.e. really
good but i rather have a
talent maybe for people and for
scenarios and somehow have the courage to
do the right things  to go and was
extremely lucky with my objects so that's better
that you can reach the fire troop is but
even yes but that can't be repeated
so if i go your schröder now
and the guy gambles with the led
tills all of a sudden in oklahoma  so
third photos east yes from or wherever he
is playing and the whole of america is
laughing his head off at him and says what an
idiot like he gambled and
so on you are also dependent on
it just because you said it as an
example and  So with him I
also looked for photographers at some point
and wrote in all the important ones and
what once he no longer reacts,
e.g  Also, it doesn’t matter at all what I am
and whatever, so I’m missing a
network, also in America, so
I have zero point zero
any contacts there and and I’m
not on the road professionally either, I do
n’t really love my private life, that is, my
professional life  it's still 70 percent
in germany and everything else is
purely private so my friends
are one is a
medical technology company the other is
real estate what so these aren't
that media people where somehow
fertilized and my career in
germany was 90 percent exactly from
things like that from yesterday evening in
the bullerei comment he says and
then it’s better that way there were jobs
created someone from lewis
hamilton i would have the perception
you started germany
national team then nico rosberg
wasser already international then lewis
hamilton what  yes it is global and then
i would have said okay with the reference
with the berg network  then
somehow let's say james is
n't far away i thought so too
and i spent two weeks here with becker
junior who is a huge
superstar and then after
two weeks and a day i couldn't do it
anymore because i was with louis  was on the road
and then the phone never
cheated again i also worked with wild with
three days after my i was in abu
dhabi there i produced something like that with lewis
from network because he
was visiting and i traded everything
and all  photos and videos
and a little viral video made
with such a silly little idea
but it worked well and he looked
super cool and the management has
a great media company then I was
then we shot something twice more
and then they did  never contacted me again
so that's a sign
that that's not at all
so I'm not mad about that, it's
just clear that my stuff isn't  ht is
good enough there is my product is
also much too interchangeable better so it
's yes now you don't have to
pretend so lebron james was namely
would call and say I'd like
a great photo like you took of
lewis hamilton  and yes I
can't today but tomorrow he says
I have to do it today because I'm there today is then he
just calls the next best person and it's
not like he says afterwards
it's a shame that paul couldn't
but arises  yes still a very,
very good photo so and and
then you really have to say again
that what i did maybe six years ago
photographically or video
graphically or whatever with
material with whatever
that is in the same quality  it's
been done forty times since then
so it's not so it wasn't
so good although it was mainly new back then
and I've
benefited disproportionately from that I think in the  photography
at the same time is also so that I was
also a bit overworked so
no idea of burnout photographically just
oesn't feel like it anymore so I hav
I was no longer controversial was I sto
ped in Formula One prett
clearly so there were there were 30 days
written down for a long time i want to
continue this every morning just from the
gut feeling he has a stand for 24 days now
because i don't
feel like going to the track today i don't feel like it
and then after a month and
then it became world champion and we
were
mexico city  I don't know and
after all I fly in a private jet at night
behind is a bus and then there's a
party, a club is rented and everyone
is there and I went home
because I was
celebrating a world champion again and then I thought to
myself you're now  you stupid or
otherwise my job is
to tell enthusiastic horny stories of one of the
greatest athletes in the world of blatant
events  ssen when I'm bored
if something has to change there so that
must never be so then I get
so bad from the products I
make and that's why I had to
make cuts and came through a thunderstorm,
so to speak, and the last two
years  and that was also something so i
met campino recently and
talked about it like
whatever and he opened his heart to
david because he gave me great
compliments about what we did
together in the dead pants
time and  what's coming on today's
page that was awesome then
we watched the videos from back then a
little funny whatever stuff
and that in turn led
to me so he then also said well
sometimes you just have to do
something for two years  don't do it and then go
back to private and and I'm
actually at the moment now and because
you mentioned lofoten I have
the last three vi  he plans to
take more photos for weeks and
has a lot of fun doing it
too, so in lofoten i think i also took a
few photos that were at least
a bit more unusual for me
and not so interchangeable
doesn't matter because i've already done a lot of
things where  i've
shown it here now he's in front of it or
you're driving now it doesn't matter 100,000 times so why do i have to take a picture of someone from the chor keller ferris wheel
that
somehow nobody needs to go to lofoten but i
had the feeling that i should bring something with me which
is and was cool  proud again and
so i would have thought after the
world championship formula 1 election campaign
would also have been awesome lakers would have been the
us direction but now in
hindsight you would have suspected scholz of
course proud to accompany it would
probably have been
great too jan raphael brinkert and since the whole thing
that  would also have been an environment what you
know
so the rea  quality is that only soder do with
me
then I twist is also cool
finds then first of all then it was there I have
already pulled it was like that
contradicts any political
so I don't know maybe that's
not a line or mine either
but I  think if he gives access
that you know you documented in your
way there we will work with relevance versus
backbone or whatever and
I have to say there
I wouldn't I would never find that
weapons group and I think there
is already relatively alone I
said really out of conviction that
my I also canceled saudi arabia as
kohlhepp eg so the questions
you can come there they invite
family first class three weeks in
sodingen and it's cool if
you tell me  that we are also really a
western side but it's
still a country that is very willing
not to advertise that's
blood money  and there is also no discussion
that was discussed last time before
i see it just as much
tobacco company that is just as
before you shouldn’t advertise it
i think so and those are my
ideologies and my conviction and
accordingly they will stay  there
and i think in politics is of
course that some are
now going to do the olympics i'm
not new to them either so it's more because of
the osb right because i think that's the
worst
missed i find horror how the work
and what's there  so she was thrilled
it hasn't been tried so much now
but you could really do that there would be a
completely different gratitude
probably much more blatant access if you
easily say with a
tobogganist or a skier and
the photos I would or would  you
probably quite a lot of people
like housing an apartment or not
because actually there my q  quality is
not enough because then the
content is not so interesting that new
fans but of course nobody actually sees the women tobogganers
there is a
reason why hockey was only played during
the world cup so it was the first so there is
no reason that not so many now
people are okay between olympique
numerous or thousands of hockey
fans and people who played the
game and this person who is the ipcc
in hockey it somehow
accompanied hockey and there are now the
pictures for that the costs are again these
20,000 euros there but what is yes  also a
good target group i would have that with my
apartment i am 100 percent convinced
that it would not be like that i think i
would not take a single picture if i accompanied
the national hockey team at the
next olympic games
and they won then i would not get a
single one  sell a photo of it for 20,000 euros
so it's just my
opinion sky don't prove we have to
i don't want to try s either
but yes well but there are other photos
it was us so but lumpi
asamer tobogganing is or or tobogganing
i don't know now but there are
also really so freaky they say
it's norbert these new sports
or just simple  this yes where he says
crass thing closer to people
crass moments like that and there are
also target groups here i would
tell you look at the power they would
be more relaxed with the
access than these super stars are now, where
everything is always very probably
specially regulated  yes, well, i would
n't have any now,
because then they've already gone,
so the German
national ice hockey team if you
ask yourself now and say come with me to
china here he's like
three sides of it and
I would actually just do the whole thing
too  because so back on so there
I lack interest and passion
for it, too, so I know what makes us
different
Relevance is very interesting for
you, so something is relevant for you and
we've known each other for a long time,
you can even if
someone is sitting there with four million
followers then you think it's
cool and if he's 17  million
sales then the eyes of the film festival open
and says from the relevant i
on the other hand really have to say if he
does [ __ ] so if
what the gentleman
brings is rubbish if oliver is pocher and really only
produces negative [ __ ] then i don’t care
if  eight million people watch that
or 8000 it still remains negative
[ __ ] like that and accordingly the
content is relevant I don't want to
now the
national ice hockey
team is guaranteed to be a great team but I
don't watch any of their games
that just interests me at
all  not and that's why I could
n't take any good photos at once,
so I understand that maybe they are
we with our inclination to sports i am
even more intense i believe that
now even if i said i
would be interested too or
do i really do everything ok and
let's actually look at the things others
because you are probably even more interested
in music  also because now
somehow as well as is to accompany or
something we there too maybe at some point
school you don't buy an
interesting case where you also there
mouth but yes probably
already but also real other generation
so she is 20 years younger than me and
me  so what was more like claudia
schiffer not bothering to
work with photographers back then this has
changed i think but you have to
understand what they do you have to have the
ideologies and the style and the music
and the statement the art of them
somehow similar  feel and I think
that's a problem if you so
I could not just 20-year-old
rapper who somehow a  lso the fact that
i speak a different language actually
their appearance and whatever
ring i adore and am a big fan
is but visually it was something i don't
understand so i think it's great to
watch but i couldn't
interpret it because i don't
because i don't feel from bietigheim the
small state a [ __ ] of water
so we are a couple of values that i just
on't understand at all that's why i cou
dn't contribute anything to ma
ing the video or something so it
s probably like that i would
't have paid that much attention  you take
pictures of weddings now if the war
comes over 50,000
which also has a story i took
my time taking photos and packed it up
completely and that was that until
today and now i get chills down my spine again
because i had more
than i have  did everything wrong what
you can do wrong so the
branch has somehow the mother of the bride
has and although no film in d  he camera it
's really not a single photo and also
apparently i said it while
taking the photo and then
actually managed to disguise it very well then
went there afterwards said i
didn't want to disturb that much beforehand that's
why we can recreate the wedding shortly
after that some do that  people
that you basically proceed again and
then the moment is the photo
re-enacted I did that and then I had the rescue to the
front and I photographed everything
well
and since it was all still on film then
you shoot it like that  camera back and
usually there is a bit of
resistance and at some point the
resistance is over because the film is
wound back into the spool and then you kind of
notice it but now
it becomes easy because now the film is in I
shot about seven minutes and
it never got easier because it was
easy the film wasn't inserted correctly
so first there was no film and then no
r  importantly inserted and there was not a
single photo of the club and the
process so the trip to canossa
then with my name i wrote myself a warm
letter and i went there and
i have to decide
again personally but i have to go there after
a minute can  it's not even now
let's solve it or
whatever you can you're just me I
'm an idiot and I'm
so jealous and I could
n't handle that so I can't actually handle that until today
I was totally  i
have no idea i have nothing left
last try so you should actually
say okay now the
probability that st pauli
noticed the time when you didn't use it
and both see what paul ii
leaders of the second division say your
near hamburg you know the area
I would take them everywhere with me immediately
to accompany them now if they have to go up in
the summer and there
is definitely everyone  If there were many thousands of
people who would buy it,
I would do that, but not because there are people
who buy it, but because I have the
feeling that I can contribute
something to FC St Pauli through my passion
and
maybe capture something that I am in
feel at the moment and what is then maybe not
otherwise there is better so that if
i had the feeling the result was
somehow relevant i.e. of some
quality and i would have that i
think that at least not completely and
that somehow and we will come back to that
to the national ice hockey team i
have the feeling that i
can't contribute anything that the photos aren't good won't like
the product and in
fact i'm not at all interested in
whether someone pays 20,000 euros for
it or not so that's
never been the reason to do anything  What
you think about the partnerships is
different at first, but
that's actually what it is  so that it is jan
eder so that makes something possible for
me anyway with american express
I can go to the lofoten and they will create
a noble new content
my followers but also a different
order so anyone who sees that
way will be enriched by it and that  let's make
it or the iwc film is something where
i tried to put my ideology together in
three minutes and since it is
and is by the way that
revealed the most successful at iwc
conradi and they are also relatively immune
exactly which is not because i'm
cooler than  if that's just
here we come back to the water tom brady
has been seen seven billion times where
doesn't tom brady have to do it again the
new ad by tom brady for whatever he's going to do
now it doesn't work on
social media so it's all
online  -marketing i think
real stories are more interesting and they
are not that broad so
tom brady will be interested in ten million
people  I'm probably interested in
10,000 and of the 10,000 there are 1,000
who are really touched and who
react in some way. Of the ten
million, only
ten may react because that's the
reality and it's in between, or
I can't explain why either
the iwc film is so disproportionately
relevant i personally goes on saying
i really tried really hard
so i scripted two months earlier
and and there is a real story
in it it's real in terms of the product
so i filmed it i edited it
so i did  so that
's about the celebrations simply the fact
that now luxury watches are also working together with people
like you that
's not even true if the content isn't
right I'll disagree with you everything has to be
right but I think it's
okay we already live there  a
change of times
just like i observed when i
first became a car company on the
podcast  what that has raised the medium
to another level
many of the same noticed but of course if
automobile advertising is the decisive
category in the field of advertising if
the three go in the podcast what it is
visually logically cars is the
same if suddenly luxury watch brand
say okay we  go and do it
now with digital creators like paul
ripke let's say
that you've already noticed, i think
maybe unconsciously, a
bit of change in the whole advertising game,
yes, because it has to become more human, you have to feel the stories
and the  again, you're a
good one better tell stories so that's
why there's the podcast
because you have all these brands that are there
and they don't do the thing boys an
absolute apropos we have to we have
to advertise and speak here again
and that's me  I have, so
I have another one here, so
now with roll 1 advertising it's a
vodaf  one
what that is it where of that i don't know
what yes also this smartphone yes
and you have to use it to make calls and
then you have to have data tariffs somehow you have to have data tariffs of some kind
then i often recognize
someone but is there someone else
there is the best one  so
you can know about it just for right now because
the masts end customer area but if you
as a business founder want to make a phone call
or somehow
want to go online with your company then
you need some nice babble
that can produce and that can probably of it
for example excellent and you
now they all don't just offer one tariff, we
permanently. there is also a package for
all the people who are in the new york
situation. the rest have to work
. the old challenge
can now be solved at vodafone by
using a cooperation
that exists  with microsoft there
are discounts of 25 cents on all
microsoft products and that means something like
cloud backup f  for the entire company
microsoft teams as a telephone system, of
course, then with vodafone tariff or
cell phones that have the entire employee
employees in companies are
secured and all times
the overall product that’s called black out
so what’s available now cheaper for
business customers, especially vodafone.de
m / 365 the goat has looked at the factory
packages and now wigs are also available from
vodafone and not just from these
other providers who are usually always
on the go. I'll take a look thanks
and speaking of the other providers, it's
also a new podcast by dian
yokoyama  fnr was since we
would have been in regularly then you couldn't
miss that also supported by a phone company
now i was surprised to
hear the podcast when mister
spock is out of the pot is how did it come about
because
he has so much to do so to be fair
he is  already a very very busy
of very very many projects
and so that's the nice thing about yoko and  the
great thing about yoko is that he's an enthusiast
so i don't know
anyone in my environment who's crazy about
sauce if you have an idea who's so
enthusiastic about people from ideas
of so and really full of real troll
enthusiasm
has of course with capacity  At some point
and I think he just doesn't have the
capacity anymore so that's so I
don't know we talked about it for a long time
and what he just has so
much on his agenda for next year that he
didn't feel comfortable continuing the
podcast  one must also
say must still in a podcast
will say top 50 top 60
moderate reach in germany so i got you
were there very early on
we were a bit nostalgic back then
at the beginning
and now to say a bit so
typical  I don't call him either there
is or would give a lot of money for it
but no but follows so he's
full of courage and ultra because for him it's
just us  we
started it as a couple and we always live according
to this principle, so
we always ask ourselves do
we want to continue and of course you can
say no for me, by the way,
my marriage too, so I ask every summer
do we want to continue together
stay 16 times so far
I also hope that a few others
will come and
I don't know what will happen
if they don't come because then but if it
doesn't take a little time
I have to say it
wasn't easy for me  to process at the beginning
because to be honest he
i want me exactly what i wanted so
i wanted and that i
actually have full
understanding for it now because it totally
makes that is for me from me when i
then my blood but i am  white
many people also want to know that's
why the justice
podcast didn't have to confirm a bit
but i'm a podcast that also
a bit  en closer that they are
now talking about significant six-figure
sums than that now not again
100,000 is significantly more than 100,000 that
would have been paid now if you simply
jeopardize pop in the next few years that
can be yes but they
should  never be the reason
to do anything and that's where I have to be
and yoko is right too and
that can be optional if something is the
duty that you want to make the
product and if the
duty isn't right then it ca
n't be  cows give so it's 100
percent the right decision
not to do it, no matter how much money, because he
's the money bearer and then of course we come
back to the dead pants, so
that should never be the reason
to do something like that, it's better like this  of course it
becomes the reason if you somehow
justify yourself about something and and of
course i'm not there either so i
find myself the ideological
whatever i want a  uch already be
rewarded for what I do but the
optimum is also when you
produce something no matter where it is whether the media
is whether it is in the podcast whether it came
so where at the end is the other side of
this exchange of performance for money
is happy and both sides say
okay that's appropriate now and so that
's at least my goal but is that
appropriate and what is what you were you
touched as a
master who's probably that's more like a
seven-figure sum he throws
millions away or yoko throws them away
and you would have  who can probably use it now
with
the parie crate on the side and they are
no longer there because she was that then
so that you are right there from
now on privately said go so that was
completely okay yes it was an ultra shock
for  me because i just got scared so i was really scared
for the first time
whether i
had miscalculated and that also happened in the
situation in which the vis  um wasn't there
so i was five years with a visa garden
investors like you the two visas
we wanted to extend that my job has
changed so much we applied five years
ago so we applied with
photo workshops for german photographer
that was a clean application  we got
five years, i did it for two
years and then i did something completely
different and this job change
has for the extension if i say
i would like to stay longer they
say but they want something completely
different and that was it  well
i he already had an identity crisis
what do i actually do what am i a
also as a toss boat and you
tell me all the time you are a
photographer and i tell you i dont ask
anymore and whatever
and that so i have  By the way,
overcome I'm a photographer,
I'm a photographer, you also call the police a bit
differently, that would be ok, or if
you listen, if you had one more time,
but  So per se it's like that
I found what I was there again
at that moment it wasn't me and of
course I got
really blatant anxiety attacks at first,
also
ideologically for myself
because I sometimes
struggle with myself how much  am I
worth what he so everything I do is
always with someone else and you
have to say that if anyone
books advertising in the podcast with us if
you
want to say it from a business point of view it is more up to yoga than to
me so it is  so so and at the same time
there is but we've
already had ten minutes about my party there
are also companies that don't want to
but that's really difficult for me to
assess and so on but it was
always like that, well, well, I was always like that
was dependent on dead
pants dependent on the dfb dependent on nico
rosberg but on lewis hamilton so
it's no coincidence yes but my
performance
somehow increased  to evaluate and to evaluate my contribution
that is actually almost impossible to put it
like that and if you then
get something taken away, which is simply
something that ends first and you
get scared then start, at least
I started that way,
that's it now because I'm alone
doesn't work at all so i was
really so good that
alone no one gives me even a
euro to do anything alone war
would have no podcast that anyone
wants to hear and whatever that
then took like a week two and
then i did  two three things change
if you talk to juncker a lot on the phone
and so on the longer it was,
the clearer it became to me that he was absolutely
right about that and that
it's not that he doesn't
feel like it anymore and that the
content bores you  or whatever he
has so many things on the title that
he
has to cut something down somewhere, so something has to be cut away and that
's natural  After all, he should also
cut away what
bothers you, so it's like that because it takes time because he has to think and think about
it ideologically
and that's why it's
exactly right and good to put it that way
, period and there
we also caught up then so it was like there
were ten days that weren't really
super easy but also very open
discussions and he's
really not afraid of conflicts so the one who
then defines with you and also
discusses it with you  early on
i think it was also very busy how
much i got out of hand that in
turn showed me that we
are friends too so that that was only legal
and that is the principle
that the people he gave
freedom to  the brand but
everyone has now also built new things
to do after all what we are now the
fact is that it also belongs to them
so we have it together and that's not the case
designing and doing warmly i think
so i'm not quite
ready yet so i did the podcast with
him i think there's a risk and
paul did a podcast that was
but i think it's right
now and it's been like this for a week now  super cool
to have a white sheet of paper on the topic of
podcast address of course we both
animals also in the preliminary talk about what
are you doing now what is there now and that
could be done that could be done
i am not under
any pressure at the moment so i find it  totally
interesting to be
completely open at first about what you
could do, anyway, see the white
sheet of paper more as
an opportunity it will now be a bit
psychologically kitchen but that is
actually an opportunity and if
I have the iwc, among other things,
we will find it  looked at again where I
say something like that, so that this
leaving situations good timing means just
starting and stopping at the right
ze  stopping at the point is never easy and of
course it's not easy for yoko either
that doing it
that way for the one for whom we as ultra difficult everything
and yet he's
surprised that it would have been easier for him that he
then pulled it off
like that somehow  to try to
do justice to all of that somehow and
maybe if we don't have any
friends anymore at some point because because it
kind of wears out and what he always
was you know we're much
better friends now than five months ago for
example so that's really something
positive private and that's much
more important to him than anything
business and
I think that's really cool in something like that I'm very
much admired very briefly by your idea
how you think I'll develop podcast advertising in
general because that's a
thing that might now be the
future  could so it could also say
because you are always brainstorming what it
could be I think I think format is good
where a wide variety of guests come
back to you regularly and you can
also gain super great people who
live exciting lives and then you say
yes that's one idea but the other
idea is that you say there is somehow
from your point of view evolution in
podcast advertising  i think so i
don't have a real one yet i
have i was at the lanserhof for example
and i have
a hotel and a lady
cleaning
fasting cure the mayersche whatever and i
haven't eaten anything for ten days and i
have whatever  and I
also put a lot of effort into it. The
reaction to the way I was
guided by what has
done to me has done a lot to me and
whatever you can listen to and the
current episode, but and then there comes more or
less  a
comprehensive
and and this experience report and
there it was no sponsoring and no
place so that I paid quite normally
and is also auc  h not exactly
cheap but for a week
so ten days i think but
depending on how for treatments you stop
i make a robot to say well
somehow its what he chooses a
clinic a private clinic yes well
i know that in the end  no chance if
yes and but above all i had
a colonoscopy a gastroscopy skin sticky from
skin cancer
preventive checkups i
have them do all the blood tests you get
infusions so the hospital is full
that tim mälzer said
recently there was and he then the ten
kilos  a week
there is a lot to eat, yes super
earlier, but
i think that this is the
experience of experiencing something and then reporting about it
, if necessary, i
can’t explain why you
don’t actually do something like that, so
why not as a brand, i think  there
's a lot of music in there, if necessary
to send you somewhere and
experience something and nothing at all  t to explain the product
but to experience a feeling so
one for services for travel for
water well there are enough things where
you can also make a lot of feeling
tangible and where it takes place more in the
content water so that’s why I
have so so you have to follow
listen to it and i think you get so
keen not at all because i did it so
well but because the experience is
so special maybe
try something like that and i think
now i hope that we will always have that
mr landside doesn't exist  but the one
who
says it's good for them too and I
believe in that too,
from the listeners that's a consequence he
while he reports in great detail about the
country is
probably so
hundreds of thousands of values possible said the manag
ment yes he thinks so  i don't
no as a wise man i can't judge at all
i just mean
any one week there let's say it
costs that simple but  10,000 euros
then 100,000 people hear that from you
or something like that then not
immediately but over the next few
months times 100 like that and then that’s
ten thousand times 101 million like that well there
’s a really big mark on that
I believe
it’s
all good  i
think and actually more will be
totally interesting that you let someone
experience something and about this
experience about i don't even know what
the term is that advertorials that you
actually
do more or less editorial work that and no longer product-side
work so that they
actually reported about it so
to come back to us now if you take the
advertisement for wahl an tig you can
on the one hand imagine what they
do i personally think it
would be nicer if you
had tested it for two weeks is here at
homer and  then told me how it
was for you and I don't even want to
know what else they do because
I want your personal listen here to
what interest I have in you how
you experienced it is a bit of an
experience what so if
jochen schweizer is doing advertising now
he would actually have to send the podcast host
whoever you are listening to there
with it  he
can report on how it is and not
just say you say it was really
cool that he can drive an excavator or
whatever is better and i
think about the level of content
that is totally interesting because you
can create really great stories and
interesting ones  content also above
all with added value for the listener
so that’s not just look
here is what I get money and you
tell you now whatever is there
but in the best case the listener gets something
from it so now with the whole thing  hof to
stay i've gotten about 100
messages in the last 24 hours
from people saying it's very
interesting i have m
I'll start reading this and that
because it's just nutritional wellbeing
whatever the topic is and that
in turn is a real
added value that doesn't even have anything to do with
advertising but actually what does to the
user and come there  we end
up going back to drugs or par or to
water whenever you manage to do
something to really touch people
that they are positive and if they are really really
mini now if you just say
three then really cool sweater then you've
done it all i think  that's
what you should do let's say
goodbye maybe a single
long squeezed but what just talked about
a visa problem that
made me think you ended up
tinkering around the country for 13 14 weeks here in Germany with almost
no permanent residence
until we saw it
too and I was hoping that he
didn't grab it in August that was
the worst of all, I also know
gene  oh what were the highlights so if
you go as a favorite now as long
as all contacts here what what had i
know really with all sorts of
people with musicians with athletes
companies at home there for a few
days we did something at some point of
course with the boat  driving and
also abseiling which the
obstler brought the praise the breakfast and of
course up the tv tower that
was really good and i got to know a few
new people who really fascinated me
krokauer then knoll and her husband seemed so strange
sex and spencer game new  is
n't that so the fight for viewers
today isn't the kidding for a
long time is then really that means that's
exactly what fashion does then yes
and makes it highly successful
because it just fell ultra and
among so among other things I have  the
times visited then I looked at it
and be like that I find these these
I called the exchange days  I
hope you just visit the members one day
. I've asked a few people that
now and that's really cool,
so that makes me super excited and I, as I
always offer to
sign India at the beginning of the disclosure
agreement that you don't say anything about it
because we are  yes also internal and
whatever they don't want but to see
that someone like krakauer is in the warehouse
and packing packages she thinks
it's really cool etc. i really have to say
that i always think it's enriching to
see how much effort is put into it  successful
people with the products give and with
the contact and with the production of
because
i've often been involved in things
where you didn't put enough
effort so let's say I put
enough effort that's it
but that's it
gone pretty quickly than so if
you really
want to work long-term then it's worth the
effort and it's also worth the attention to
detail and it's worth it  h
to think about it for another five minutes and
maybe prepare a bit better
and maybe be
a bit cheaper
too and not just take the 65 euros
with you because you could
experience it I found the combination totally fascinating
and I think that was it  so
that what i really touched me deeply in
between and what i
lost a bit maybe also
because of the distance through germany
whatever is how many people are
willing to help if
you asked them for help i found it so
I asked him for help and
I said you can I
need someone I would be interested then
he says call about tomorrow 8 p.m. and
then he calls the day after tomorrow at 8 p.m.
water so a license plate number it is
so reliable then
that  you can do that with quite a lot of
people and i do that with
other people too, so if you
ask me for tutoring i think  e only i
can only talk about myself that i didn't
ask enough people for help also for
support also better to
say so in the end it will help me if
you post it is dark with the link
because we have too much
I ordered too much of that one jumper or
something like that then it's not as common
as you think so we Germans
tend to hope we're
celebrating because maybe we're too
satirical people looking at
life and stuff like that  think
it's good somehow but it's actually a lot a
lot sexier
support and supporting each other and doing something for each other
and if necessary a
bit more and it's
people you met
on the trip or porsche type was after
carnival did you see that before  this
porsche refiner 22-year-old guy who
just builds a new car also thinks
that i found deeply fascinating
then i had a ne there i was at
lake constance in überlingen
überl  Egen I'm watching music so I
don't know you know that marching
band carnival music moderately super cool
a scene that I wasn't aware of
young people who always called up and
then new songs like that aren't that good at all
but 60 man band but super female  and
an energy that i've never experienced like this
before and doesn't exist in my life
before that, but i think you
've applied for a marching
how's the
conference going because i wrote down one thing
how will it work so how  how's it going
so we're in full swing we'll have
some rest of course
worrying about good
hesse virus topic at some point but we think we can do
it, especially since it's still a
while away one is certainly branch and
so but we now have the first
speakers and we have a lot
people are very interested in talking about it
, there is also great support that people
say I've been asked why he
was just going there and mac  hte also a lot of
interest from partners so that
looks good
and i think he is wendt i
think i hope that people will also say
that because we will also be stars and
musicians from the league i think
it was because of our trouble there
many, many top stars
that looks really good from the usa i had
just met the first
kutcher here in the podcast too
i would say you have to always
pay for which flights are not very
cheap because then and so reluctantly there is
not now  come it's not exactly
what you can afford but
things like that it's already full and
is because so theoretically that's
actually an incredible chance
he's got with the conference
I think because you're actually a
blank sheet then  paper has so I hope you
don't do exactly the same thing this
spring as you
would have done three years ago, but a
new bonus so that's that  my new
different because the needs are one
hundred percent different than three
years ago it can never be exactly the
same as it was before the mistakes
and that's super cool or
have so is I mean that was
honestly because of the
growth in the  year before that still
so that in what I think was eight
years ago we had three different locations
, inevitably very different
setups then you have more and more
possibilities it occurred to me people we
could do other things so and
it will be like that again now asking is
just what it is  can be exact so a
bit of course i also have
ok let's do a meat-free
one i honestly
talked to him about it now he
did the bulling then made the lunch
meat-free for a while now after corona and that was
n't well received  then budget okay I'm coming here
now that means bullerei will the
cl eat meat on the basis of that
you then almost learned very small
or with lunch thought okay
then you're doing something right
maybe but a lot of people are
annoyed and say why
do you have to prescribe now and why does he come
around the corner so radically and
I can't  would like to eat from münster myself
and so that means we
think about things and see where we are going
, of course
we also developed or bought sustainability topics together with atze schröder in
this forest
where we are now
planting trees ourselves so that we don’t just
do our thing  do somewhere in
africa where they know exactly what they
actually do themselves
so come on things like that and that they also
the whole event picture maybe
so built that's there
things will be new but i think a
lot of things are of course even if  the
star is also in there,
no, that's clear, but it will still be
different,
so I've got a bag  hey yes i have
i am looking for a great job exchange
i have advertised a few jobs yes
just a personal assistant
somewhere i don't give a [ __ ] where but
someone after that so an assistant that
is no knowledge organizing so
really shares his whatsapp i
would like so  i was still
in america and has someone who can be reached for demos in the
afternoon and evening
if the time difference and in the
morning i don't care and i especially
liked having someone who just had
briefings and appointments in the morning and i
'm pretty careless  also
not being able to cut anything
technical i have a hangover in the
summer and it's
not really all just organization and our
things that really maybe even
closer to yes, to that in terms of strength than
to really creative work now
because conceptualizing and so on
doing that  I do everything myself and I have to do it
myself, so I can't
hand it over  and that doesn't make
any sense either,
so podcast-wise, what I'm missing right now,
so I don't know how I
want to continue or whether I want to continue or
what I want to continue, I personally
have to say that I'm very, very proud
and I really really like that  so that
fills me with a lot of
life to have this order so that that that
that i that i reach people that
people hear me there i
feel very lucky and that
is a great motivation to
continue something so far because yes  because it is
very, very enriching for me per se
without yoko i somehow lack a kind of
opponent of course because i
have exchanged ideas with him a lot i
have this and that so it was something in
common and i'm
a bit like that in the conception and
this and that and that i said with a
martial led conversation last
year just have a podcast
editors you need a free
podcast re  Dakteur who may
also sometimes if you then record something
also sometimes so I would also need
I would actually like to advertise
with the recording I would actually
also like to be able to correct me
if I’m talking nonsense again
so also sometimes in the place but before  especially
someone who has good ideas when you make
guests who has good ideas for just someone
who likes to listen to podcasts with a passion
and does so more freely so it
wasn’t a permanent job or
whatever just someone you
can sit somewhere with and that  then
somehow something with completely unclear where you are
looking for something like that but at least regardless
of what I'm doing I'll be
talking to someone like that every month about
what ideas are what
you can do that should have proven itself as
appreciation probably listen to the apa
red  dot com there is a job
page because
dot comes and then it is job and then
somehow mp dp
counter and we have too
working students we are we now
also have a working student which i thought was crap it
was so
i stopped having interns and working students
and earlier in the photo studio you were
ever in my studio here
norderstedt i always had one intern per department
and so many  Germans
then say yes exploitation and that's
an impertinence and if you
find yourself upset about kliemann again
that he supposedly doesn't pay his people
properly or whatever else that really upsets
me, i.e. me
personally the number of people at
makes it pays the yearly anyway
but apart from that the chances that the
crowd of people who got a chance and
really a relevant
change in their lives from fan
kliemann that fits
I don't even think a football increase because there
's really anything to say for the
type of really so many people  so
incredibly positively influenced increased what
I would have also ic  h to be honest
I think the unpaid internships we
don't do that but I think or I would have
done it myself earlier
as an intern so I did it so tomorrow I got the train to get in that
way I would have worked for eight weeks three
months for nothing because you're there
already takes so much out so it's
not a plea according to the motto all
interns otherwise we don't do it
here either but
i think it would have been okay
and i looked for it because i would have
liked to have worked for certain companies back
then and dark ok fuller can
and but  Well, it's different from
what you do again and if that's not the case, we're
doing student trainees now because
at least that's not the case, but in the
end I also see a much
greater chance of
really looking into somewhere and
we've had the last two  years also by being knocked
out and home office and whatever
, we just stopped doing it
better so naturally  so that's what you hear if you
don't have an office if you don't have
instructions so the chance no
longer makes sense if someone has to sit at home
and finish excel spreadsheets that's
an
interpersonal chance
but we're slowly coming
back to that I have  in heidelberg to an
office there the two of them are sitting and then there are
now three and then we’re still looking for
a working student and then we’ll see
what happens there okay okay a
few more jobs
jobs or quite a lot but dared to
do a podcast directly if I then at some point because
I am  very happy where I am right now
but you know that means that
maybe they don't
feel like me it was never so the door is
always open we were interested here at the time,
also on the
best of terms,
separately, don't sit
here now and if so that  would of course
be very interesting for us to hear
what's coming and who knows
when we'll be able to play again
we would certainly like to do that in the
sense that we were there and yes
all of you at the latest next year at this
time there will be the next match
maybe i would like to do it again earlier
we will see you at the festival and so on
at the latest or you can go to
one after the other  looking but not really looking,
yes i have now where i
hope i can get in then it
sounds daring if i
don't jump over the border
now if not now when then you will come
to my house a long time later
i have a good guest
nico backspin
is also somehow so with my
stanggassinger schmidt the
weapon against private is
not presented so maybe someone else
is private and yes I am worried that
is a lot of money I think he was
looking if you don’t believe that then it
works a hundred percent yes but that
here is a trip right tightened again last week
do you know how
tightened test that the test is now
only one day more  h is valid and not
3 I think but of course I have
no idea that it's possible
it's slowly getting better maybe it
's February now anyway
so I know straightaway wins in the super bowl I know nobody's playing so I'm playing so it's going to
be right  drive through and that's
true the game is a badass
stadium it says chosen for life
that's the baddest thing so it's so
crazy you think so when you're
in there you think okay I'm in
virtual reality
[music]
[music  ]